avec nous sur ce plateau dominique
pradalié secrétaire générale du syndicat
national des journalistes bonjour
bonjour merci d'avoir accepté notre
invitation julian assange est donc
accusée d'espionnage il risque d'être
extradé vers les etats-unis où il
encourt une peine de 100 75 ans de
prison pour avoir publié sur son site
wikileaks des documents secrets
quel est pour vous l'enjeu ce procès on
peut dire que c'est une partie d'échecs
au niveau mondial entre ceux qui veulent
cacher et ceux qui veulent savoir ce
qu'ils veulent cacher en l'occurrence
les états y et d'amérique veulent cacher
ce que c'est une guerre ceux qui veulent
savoir c'est ce qu'ils veulent savoir
pourquoi on l'a fait et quelles sont les
conséquences
ça c'est le point principal
d'achoppement entre l'amérique de trempe
et julien assange et les défenseurs de
la liberté de la presse
julian assange a révélé au monde entier
ce que c'était qu'une guerre qui la
paient qui la faisaient pour quelles
raisons et cetera une assange a révélé
au monde entier les écoutes des presses
des principaux chefs d'état européens et
asiatiques d'ailleurs dont trois chefs
d'état français les écoutes qui sont
absolument inconnu est faite par les
états unis d'amérique
c'est à dire que l'espionnage que
l'amérique de trains accusent assange
de faire 18 chefs d'inculpation rien que
ça c'est espionnage en fait c'est
d'amérique espionne l'amérique de trump
évidemment qui espionne et pour nous
tous
l'enjeu c'est la liberté d'informer et
d'être informé
vous voyez ce procès aussi comme un
procès politique tout est politique
quand on informe tout est politique
quelle est la nécessité pour les
citoyens c'est de savoir pourquoi ils
payent des impôts
or les guerres sont faites avec les
impôts qu'ils payent donc il est
absolument normal d'informer sur les
guerres c'est la liberté d'expression
qui est en jeu aujourd'hui la liberté
d'informer vous l'avez dit qu'on quel
est l impact de ces révélations de
wikileaks au plan journalistique et quel
sera l'impact de la décision judiciaire
à la suite de ce procès sur le travail
des journalistes alors l'impact des
révélations de julian assange a été
mondiale certains même 10 et un
bienfaiteur mondial de l'humanité qui
veut savoir
tous les médias ont repris ces
informations que ce soit de la vidéo que
ce soit du texte que ce soit des photos
tous les médias du monde entier l'ont
fait et heureusement pour informer leurs
concitoyens
maintenant l'impact une décision
d'extradition serait une catastrophe
pour le monde entier une catastrophe
médiatique pour l'information est une
catastrophe juridique aussi parce que
cela voudrait dire que la loi des états
unis d'amérique et maintenant la loi
commune pour le monde entier et on
n'aurait plus qu'à s'y plier donc de
toutes les façons cette extradition est
une catastrophe si elle devait être
prononcée par des tribunaux anglais et
mais en quoi est ce que cette accusation
d'espionnage qui elle était
confirmer lors de ce procès en quoi
est-ce qu'elle pèserait sur le futur
travail des journalistes un peu partout
dans le monde tout simple oui si la loi
américaine s'applique d'abord elle
montre comme une sorte de phare des
tournées de 2,2 de son ca de ces bonnes
conditions de fonctionnement
elle implique que désormais tout ce qui
de près ou de loin tous les états unis
d'amérique que je connais peu de gars
dans le monde où il n'y soit pas soit
physiquement par des soldats soit par du
matériel militaire soit par des avions
donc toutes informations concernant les
conflits serait interdite sous peine
pour les journalistes d'être traité d'
espions en vertu d'une loi dont je vous
rappelle qu'elle date de 1917
c'est à dire en pleine guerre mondiale
est ce que vous partagez l'appel de ces
députés qu'ils te demandent à la france
d'accorder l'asile politique à julian
assange
le syndicat national des journalistes
demandent au président macron même par
écrit l'a déjà fait de donner asile à
quelqu'un dont on pourrait s'honorer
dans la patrie des droits de l'homme
d'être le comme le défenseur et il
s'agit pas de dire j'aime bien ça j'aime
pas assange et cetera il s'agit de
reconnaître qu'il a fait un travail
utile nécessaire
deux journalistes et il faut reconnaître
d'ailleurs à cet égard que lui comme la
fédération internationale des
journalistes et toutes celles et ceux
qui le soutiennent tiennent depuis 10
ans contre la cia et contre aujourd'hui
l'amérique de trump qui a tout tenté
pour l'enlever qui a tout tenté pour le
salir
eva joly
l'ancienne magistrate anti-corruption
maintenant avocate vient de révéler
qu'en islande un avion entier de n'diaye
était venu dans l'idée d'essayer de
mettre la main sur un singe qui était
réfugié là bas ce moment là c'est à dire
ses dix ans de guerre entre ceux qui
veulent savoir et ceux qui veulent
cacher encore une fois maintenant
espérons que la justice de grande
bretagne prendra en considération ce
qu'est une démocratie
merci beaucoup on suivra ce procès en
cours à londres merci dominique pradalié
secrétaire générale du snj le syndicat
national des journalistes merci à vous